the role of the library within the
community is to be a space for everyone
we try to accommodate everyone the
libraries come a long way and last
decade or so we have a lot more digital
stuff we're trying to keep up with the
times and offer people the sort of
things that they can't necessarily get
at home we're trying to like live all
the playing field as far as offering
Internet and computers and a lot of our
other digital fun stuff for kids we have
got a set of tin tablets that kids can
come in and use we use it for
stop-motion lego and stuff like that
during the holidays we also have some
robots which teach kids about coding
plus they're really fun to play with we
have a training suite with eight
computers and that's where we hold our
minecraft club and our digi Club which
is also very popular we also have a
green screen and a photography letting
sit up we hear at them we can go
archived we are here to safeguard
Southlands history basically we have a
lots of stuff here we have selling
education board records we have a local
authority stuff like council records we
have community records as well we take
donations and from public that's how we
have record such is war letters which
were in the process of doing now I'm
scanning them we're getting them
transcribed so when we receive donations
we take custodianship of the item down
donors can come in and he'll obviously
have a look at the item we do alone it
back to them if it is in really good
condition we do hold it in heat and
humidity controlled room and we take the
best care of it there's the best place
for it obviously people can come in and
take photographs and we will provide
access for them the children's area of
the library caters for 0 through to
about 30
and there is a bit of a crossover with
our teens area which is a separate part
of the library we provide preschool
programming in the way of Reglan rhyme
and story times which they aimed at as
their a tattoos for regulan rhyme into
five story times we also provide a
variety of after-school clubs that run
during the term we also run school
holiday programs and over our Christmas
holidays we run the ad giant program of
the year which is s Summer Reading
Challenge so the teens area of the
library caters from the ages of about
eleven to twelve through to eighteen and
we're running some really cool events at
the moment so we have a D s night that
happens monthly you can come along with
your Nintendo and catch up with a whole
pile of other like-minded teens and game
and we're also running a board game
night once a month as well and if you
want to know more information about this
just check out our website we also have
a great pile of resources available for
students these do include things like
the road code and all the NCAA study
guides are available for borrowing as
well so we offer a range of things for
adults who come in to use the library
and we've got quiet study areas we've
also got noisy areas downstairs we have
free internet computers that you can go
onto for up to an hour a day each we
have printing scanning and various
services like that as well
we also offer things that you can access
from home we have ebooks available as
well as a audiobooks we also have
newspapers online that people connect
this from home after library members and
we also have all these standard things
that you would commonly associate with
the library or your books magazines
graphic novels and DVDs
you